c'est vous qui avez fait le nettoyage
bon on va recommencer parce que il va
falloir tout nettoyer correctement
bonjour donc on va faire une petite
inspection
alors qu'est-ce que vous êtes en train
de faire ici
pour aller m'expliquer ce que vous êtes
en train de
on fait pas comme ça ils ont enlevé tout
de suite tout et vous décongeler dans le
frigo ça c'est pas bon d'accord allez-y
tout de suite Gilles est inspecteur des
services vétérinaires on décongèle pas
comme ça l'eau chaude parce qu'on
maîtrise pas la température ou à l'eau
froide quand vous allez les remettre
là-bas il contrôle l'hygiène des
restaurants de la Côte d'Azur
allez
ça s'est mis en fonction ça va être
utilisé après vous êtes en train de
faire la mise en place enlever votre
montre
tout ça là
ça c'est sale c'est pas nettoyer
régulièrement donc ça ça arrive et il y
a un risque de contamination pour les
dents vous allez manipuler c'est tout
c'est pas plus compliqué que ça
bon alors
ça c'est fait pour être là dedans
l'été pendant que les vacanciers
profitent de la plage des hommes et des
femmes de l'ombre veille ils sont
inspecteurs la direction départementale
de la protection des populations
restaurants supermarché mais aussi
camping ou club de vacances rien
n'échappe à leur contrôle
[Musique]
sur les bords de la Sorgue dans le
Vaucluse les adeptes du canoë-kayak ne
le savent pas
mais ils sont sous la protection de
Marie Carmen
donc en fait ils sont numérotées
on regarde un petit peu
spécialisé dans le contrôle des
installations sportives et hôtelière en
fait il faut que toujours l'endroit où
l'enfant va s'asseoir et tout soit
toujours très lisse il y a pas de risque
ou de coupure ou des charges et tout ça
j'aimerais s'il vous plaît que vous
montrez ce que vous avez un stock en
termes de loup de dorade et de l'autre
en Camargue
Ivan lui et spécialiste des produits de
la mer très consommés en été ils sont
une des principales sources d'infections
alimentaires origine Chine du grossiste
aux restaurateurs ils passent toute la
filière au peigne fin
[Musique]
dans le Var Lucien et Marie Dominique
eux travaillent en famille
et leur spécialité ce sont les marchés
provençaux qui parfois peuvent être des
pièges à touristes l'étiquetage n'est
pas conforme aux normes spécifiques à
l'huile d'olive
[Musique]
des fois quelques grosses affaires
démarres comme ça avec quand on a des
petits indices collés bout à bout c'est
comme une enquête de police là c'est
pareil vous n'avez pas de facture encore
tous tracent relâchent les fraudes et
les contrefaçons pour garantir la
sécurité des consommateurs ils devront
se montrer particulièrement vigilants le
temps d'un été à la DDPP
[Musique]
au Grau-du-Roi dans le Gard
Ivan et Jean-Pierre ressemblent à des
touristes comme les autres pourtant ils
sont en mission
tu peux passer à côté de gens qui vont
faire du gestion en vacances il passe
des vacances bien mérité pour eux
j'imagine tu vois ça nous fait ni chaud
ni froid voilà par contre après quand on
est en vacances
aucune sincèrement tu es frustrée non de
les voir faire du jet-ski tu préfères
pas rentrer au bureau voir ton chef
franchement que faire du jet skier et
voilà
il doit être soulagé il se dit ah il
prend pas la direction de ma boutique
donc ouf
Ivan et Jean-Pierre sont en quête d'une
spécialité locale un coquillage très
apprécié des touristes la telline
Jean-Pierre il y a effectivement des
tellines pour faire la vente et là les
tellines du premier coup d'oeil tu
t'aperçois
voilà
est-ce que tu peux t'occuper des gens
toutes les factures sont là si le pot il
y a la maison
ils font voilà ils veulent voir pour les
produits
[Musique]
alors le problème des ténines c'est des
tellines locales
il y en a qu'une à retenir pour les
tellines c'est 2,5,5 cm mais là moi je
regrette le fait pas 2,5
de la des deux extrémités là on est à
deux hein
[Musique]
le fardage ça à l'époque c'était vrai
pour les fruits et légumes on mettait
les beaux fruits en dessous du cajou et
voilà mais même des cailloux des fois à
la place
mais là
l'homme peut y passer la journée
quand on parle avec des gens qui pêchent
les tellines ils sont quand même très
souvent dans le déni
ouais ils doivent considérer que la
réglementation n'est pas et mal faite
que cette métier dur ça doit trouver que
c'est un métier durant ça c'est pas le
sauf que c'est pas le sujet taxi c'est
un métier très dur c'est pas pour autant
qu'il faut pas respecter le code de la
route enfin je pense je sais pas je suis
pas gendarme mais moi je suis pas payé
au PV moi ce que j'aimerais c'est que
l'été lignes qui soit sur le marché le
soir conforme c'est tout
bon là c'est un réel problème
pendant qu'ils vont vérifier les télines
Jean-Pierre lui a repéré quelques
indices lui laissant craindre un manque
d'hygiène
ments
on fait la recherche
bactériologique sur sur ces produits là
de façon à apprécier à la fois la
caractère de dangerosité du produit
éventuellement et l'état sanitaire en
lui-même
ça me dégrade un peu dans mon travail
parce que voilà moi je sais que je
travaille
correctement ne pas le plus correctement
du monde parce que d'une année à l'autre
on en rajoute toujours au niveau de
l'hygiène ça devient bientôt plus
possible de travailler pour les
résultats du laboratoire il faudra
attendre plusieurs jours faites
attention à vouloir déjà trop trop
attirer le chaland des fois on se trompe
ou on le trompait donc
pour les tellines en revanche le patron
doit s'acquitter d'une amende de 1500
euros
et c'est clairement quelque chose de pas
bien je l'assume on le laisse comme ça
je vais pas faire jeter ça dans les
poubelles
ça me fait mal au cœur regarde ça elles
peuvent être consommées mais mais c'est
pas bien j'espère que la sanction de
financière permettra de dissuader ce
genre de choses
il faut que vous nettoyez donc du coup
effectivement bon courage merci la loi
impose de détruire toute denrées jugé
dangereuse les tellines sont trop
petites mais ils vend les estimes
consommables
près de Nice dans la petite station
balnéaire du Cannet
Gilles va faire une découverte beaucoup
moins agréable
il arrive par surprise dans ce
restaurant
le responsable ce monsieur bonjour
monsieur planzis de la dddp sécurité
sanitaire des aliments je vais faire une
inspection dans votre établissement
les gens rentrent pas dans une cuisine
n'importe comment
[Musique]
allez c'est parti monsieur vous êtes en
train de travailler en cuisine à partir
du moment où vous êtes en train de
travailler en cuisine on doit être en
tenue de travail une tenue de travail
conforme il doit comporter au moins
comme votre comme mon employé comme
votre employé chaussures pantalon
vareuse
ça marche pas comme ça
lui en tenue vous l'êtes pas ça c'est
pas bon
l'été la chaleur pose de gros problèmes
sanitaires surtout dans les frigos
quelle est la température c'est entre 3
4 ça dépend oui mais là il est à
température là mais à l'intérieur ça
doit tourner entre 0 et 4 écoutez moi
non mais j'ai tout attendez
il faut que je travaille en même temps
donc écoute-moi pour en discuter les
règles on discuter après mais là vous
avez m'écouter d'accord les températures
qui doivent régner ici doivent être
maximum 4 degrés Celsius on est déjà sur
l'afficheur digital à 5 mais est-ce que
c'est vraiment le cas mettez votre
thermomètre docteur et après on verra ah
oui là en effet il y a plus trop de
poignées
vous allez voir des surprises
si je vous dis ça c'est pas pour une
alarme
5,7 degrés Celsius donc tout le stock
est là le stock il y a de la mise en
place là après je vais vous montrer j'ai
une chambre froide
là vous allez tirer les cheveux mais
j'en ai plus
ajouté les oreilles alors ça c'est la
partie sous-sol on a arrangé comme on a
pu c'est pas trop mal
voilà
là on vient de faire de la purée donc on
l'a mis aphrodir vous allez me dire
normalement il faut une cellule de
refroidissement aussi je sais pas que je
vais vous le dire c'est sûr
pas boulets qu'on fasse ensemble tous
les établissements et tout c'est plus
souvent puis on verra vous avez pas de
cellules donc vous vous arrêtez de faire
ça
on ferme l'établissement je sais pas ce
que je vous dis vous arrêtez de faire ça
ou vous acquérez une série devait
refroidissement pas de souci allez-y on
va remonter ça n'a rien à faire là
vous attendez quoi
c'est moi qui l'ai surgelé
comment quand
il y a
je vous montrer la facture après je
lirai j'ai défait tout de suite et je
l'ai survé
[Applaudissements]
aucune preuve comment aucune preuve
[Musique]
la viande a pu être congelé plusieurs
fois ce qui est très dangereux
allez montrez-moi les factures voilà
c'est quoi c'est une facture
et voilà la facture où il a dû me
l'envoyer avant donc la marchandise elle
est arrivée est là le 3 0 6
on sait pas s'il a eu une transformation
c'est à dire une congélation une
surgélation quelque chose comme ça il y
a pas d'information on sait pas quand on
sait pas qui c'est pas comment je vais
mettre je vais mettre un avertissement
ça veut dire que la prochaine fois il
aura une contravention et Gilles et du
genre incorruptible
mon nom ça va merci
cette fois aucune souplesse les viandes
sans étiquette sont détruites
vous savez c'est vous qui prenez là
votre truc là la prochaine fois bah
écoutez vous commandez vous gardez les
étiquettes
la première fois il faut toujours une
première fois oui je sais d'accord et
j'espère que ce sera la dernière
merci beaucoup merci
pour l'instant la prochaine fois mais
faites le nécessaire pas de souci
dans la profession Gilles c'est taillé
la réputation d'un inspecteur
intransigent et il l'assume en trois
mois lui et ses collègues des
Alpes-Maritimes ont fait procéder à 14
fermetures de restaurants
demain il ira voir le dernier d'entre
eux pour envisager une réouverture
mais une surprise l'attend
sur le littoral les dangers et les
arnaques ne sont pas que dans les
restaurants
près de Toulon en Provence Lucien et
Marie Dominique se sont levés tôt ce
matin pour faire le marché
Dominique vivent tes travaillent
ensemble
ces deux inspecteurs de la DDPP tracent
les étiquettes des produits régionaux
vendus au touristes
ils se font d'abord passer pour des
touristes
alors
moi j'ai des varices et des esclaves de
l'hypertension de la bronchite de la
migraine
la répression des fraudes
musculaire les cervicales et dorsales et
lombaires les coudes les genoux le talon
d'Achille ça va tout simplement des
nouvelles
provençal non
en français donc il faut y aller une
contre étiquette quelque part dessus
dessous qui donne un minimum
d'informations
non pas toi mais en français
ça reste pas
par la soupe provençal
mais à quoi
vous continuez à le vendre pas de
problème mais mettez une contre
étiquette avec la traduction sur ce
marché provençal il y a un produit qu'il
surveille particulièrement car il fait
l'objet de nombreuses fraudes c'est
l'olive
les condiments en fait des produits
dérivés de l'olive
non mais le pays avec juste l'indication
d'un lot donc
[Musique]
le responsable de ce stand nous indique
qu'il achète les peaux comme ça sans
étiquette juste avec un numéro de lot là
il y a un risque de botulisme
[Musique]
donc nous la constatation de produits
comme ça non étiqueté on vient vous
croire vous les revenus recevez comme ça
en revanche
la responsabilité du produit alors que
ça n'est pas vous qui avez fabriqué au
départ vous allez les documents de
collègue vous a parlé du risque
botulisme or c'est pas comme on voit le
mal partout c'est pas ça mais vous avez
entendu parler Avignon il y a quelques
années il y a eu un cas de botulisme
grave avec de la tapenade et le gros
culisme enfin je sais pas si vous savez
ce que c'est mais ça peut ça peut
entraîner la mort il y a des il y a des
dégâts énormes derrière dans certains
cas mais là là il faut être il faut être
vigilant là-dessus c'est la raison pour
laquelle on vous l'indique on insiste
sur ce type de produit
l'étiquetage n'est pas conforme aux
normes spécifiques à l'huile d'olive on
n'a pas l'origine de l'huile d'olive
même si l'indique huile d'olive de velo
vélo
Rhône les huiles et les olives ce qu'il
faut savoir c'est que la France produit
uniquement 10% de ce que l'on consomme
autant les olives que les huiles grosso
modo c'est ça ce qui veut dire que dans
n'importe quel circuit de distribution
neuf fois sur 10 c'est pas un produit
français les olives en général c'est
Maroc Espagne encore une fois c'est pas
un problème de qualité on dit pas que
les olives du Maroc sont pas bonnes ou
les olives d'Espagne sont pas bon c'est
pas ça le problème c'est que il faut pas
non plus laisser croire aux clients que
on a des olives françaises des olives de
la région
[Musique]
c'est peut-être mieux
mais on ne vous oblige pas bonne journée
allez bonne journée au revoir
de retirer le produit parce que
manifestement il y a pas de d'éléments
en plein sanitaire et de danger
particulier mais vu la multitude
d'anomalies sur l'étiquetage les
l'étiquette qui est pas bien collé
on peut penser que c'est relativement
artisanal et qui dit artisanal des fois
on tombe sur des petits faiseurs qui
font des coups comme ça et de l'huile
qui est prétendue française
on se retrouve avec de l'huile
d'espagnol au milieu du Maroc ou jeux de
jeunes ce jour-là le vendeur a accepté
l'intervention des inspecteurs
mais ce n'est pas toujours le cas
dans quelques jours Lucien et Marie
Dominique vont devoir agir sous
protection policière
dans le Vaucluse la Sorgue fait le
bonheur des vacanciers
malgré son apparence paisible cette
rivière est parfois dangereuse
d'évacuation ceci est juste un test
Monique et Marie Carmen sont
inspectrices de la répression des
fraudes aujourd'hui elle contrôle ce
camping situé sur les rives de la Sorgue
rassembler à l'entrée du camping tous
les campings sont équipés du même
message pour une évacuation des
alarme sert à prévenir les touristes en
cas d'inondation
est-ce que vous allez bien compris le
message oui
l'inondation on sait ce que ça peut
faire quand vous arrivez à certains
endroits et que vous avez encore le
professionnel qui vous dit oh mais moi
depuis 40 ans ou 50 ans j'ai pas été
inondé je veux dire ça pour moi je peux
pas l'entendre c'est pas possible c'est
pas possible n'a jamais été inondé donc
voilà les deux collègues sont
spécialisés dans l'hôtellerie et les
hébergements de vacances
dans ce camping elles vont inspecter
chaque mètre carré là il va falloir
penser un petit peu et redonner un petit
coup de peinture là et tout ça en fait
il faut que toujours l'endroit où
l'enfant va s'asseoir et tout soit
toujours très lisse il y a pas de risque
ou de coupure ou des chars de tout ça
donc celui-là il faut voir bon là vous
voyez ça là voilà là voilà parce que de
partout regardez ça accroche
il faut absolument éviter qu'il y ait
des risques avec des écharpes et tout ça
ouais peut-être penser peut-être changer
carrément le revêtement quoi
dans ce que j'appelle un peu la
maintenance quotidienne là il faudrait
passer et balayer un petit coup un petit
peu les graviers parce que là c'est
juste bon pour que pour qu'un gamin
mettre le pied sur un gravier et tombe
ok en fait c'est à nous de d'anticiper
et d'enlever tout ce qui peut créer un
risque pour eux voilà parce que les
gamins vous voyez ben ils vont ils
jouent donc voilà
voilà
Marie Carmen et Monique ne sont pas
seulement là pour sanctionner
mais aussi pour aider les professionnels
du tourisme à satisfaire leurs clients
la problématique c'est que si les
établissements sont mal entretenus et
tout ça va être forcément des plaintes
ça va bon alors à l'heure actuelle en
plus avec internet c'est catastrophique
parce que de toute façon ça ce véhicule
a une vitesse et donc ça va être au
détriment quand même du département
c'est une grosse partie de l'économie
nous le tourisme donc on a intérêt à ce
que les gens repartent contents voilà
donc vous n'avez pas mais depuis
quelques années de plus en plus de
particuliers ouvre des maisons d'hôtes
un nouveau terrain de chasse pour ses
inspectrices
anis au siège de la direction
départementale de la protection des
populations
Gilles débute sa journée
lui ne manque pas de terrain de chasse
5 6 7 et 8 plaintes à faire
ok c'est quel genre de plainte alors ici
on a une pseudo toxine infection
alimentaire donc on voit la traiter en
plainte c'est sur une camion pizza
des plinthes adressées par des
consommateurs
supermarché la viande est verdâtres
passer de couleur je le fais surtout car
beaucoup de personnes âgées se servent
dans ce magasin et risque une
intoxication alimentaire
et ici
nous sommes regardés votre connaissance
des éléments difficilement acceptable en
matière d'hygiène catastrophique de A à
Z que ce soit de l'état des chaises aux
toilettes en passant par les cuisines le
personnel etc etc rien n'y coupent ce
restaurant Gilles le connaît bien
donc on va faire le restaurant et on
verra bien ce qu'on trouve
il a ordonné la fermeture de ses
cuisines la semaine dernière
si tu es dans le Vieux-Nice il
présentait des risques sanitaires élevés
Gily retourne pour décider s'il peut
rouvrir l'établissement
bonjour
si ça sert à rien il faut l'éliminer
sinon il faut le nettoyer
bonjour monsieur
c'est vous qui avez fait le nettoyage
bon on va recommencer parce que il va
falloir tout nettoyer correctement
il va falloir il va falloir recommencer
tout comme tout complètement je vous
explique
regardez là
tout ça ça va être nettoyé
[Musique]
par contre quand je vais revenir là on a
un problème de joint quand même regardez
ça ferme pas bien donc forcément
regardez ça marche pas bien
nettoyage vous reprenez le nettoyage
ça bouge encore ça bouge encore là
je sais c'est trop tôt
c'est encore vivant
c'est problème
jamais jamais ils sont tous morts
vous avez le siphon qui est encore
bouché là
on va aller voir juste en bas pour voir
pour vérifier
la fuite a été réparée non
quand est-ce qu'elle sera réparé la
fuite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est moyen
allez
encore un traitement ou attendre deux
jours de plus bon alors le problème
c'est que
les insectes sont en train de mourir
mais ils sont encore là
regardez donc c'est pas encore nettoyé
moi je peux pas laisser l'établissement
ouvert si on a encore une infestation et
il faut absolument il faut absolument
que les frigos sont en fonction d'accord
allez je vous laisse parce que de toute
façon vous avez du boulot
allez pour voir si c'est ok au revoir
monsieur
pour les gérants cette fermeture d'une
semaine ce sont des milliers d'euros de
chiffre d'affaires en moins
pour éviter ce genre de désagrément
mieux vaut se conformer aux demandes des
inspecteurs c'est en tout cas le choix
qu'a fait le restaurant du Cannet
averti par Gilles la semaine dernière
[Musique]
alors ça c'est un calamar minute avec
des frites maison
le persil on y va s'il vous plaît la
salle alors un calamar
depuis l'inspection quelque chose a
changé dans son établissement
[Musique]
alors ça c'est quoi ça voilà donc par
rapport à cette visite de l'inspecteur
sur l'hygiène enfin les conformités etc
donc on a fait l'achat de cette cellule
de refroidissement et voilà ça refroidit
les éléments
ça coûte cher le passage à l'inspecteur
quand même bah écoutez n'importe comment
c'était un achat prévu mais oui
un outil comme ça coûte à peu près
3-3000 euros mais bon enfin voilà c'est
quand même une nécessité maintenant dans
dans notre métier d'avoir des outils
performants adaptés aux nouvelles règles
d'hygiène etc donc là dessus il y a pas
de souci voilà c'était c'est un outil
vraiment indispensable
cet investissement pour lui c'est le
prix de la tranquillité
au gros du roi pendant leur pause
déjeuner Jean-Pierre et Yvan préfère
oublier pendant une heure qu'ils sont
inspecteurs à la répression des fraudes
mais ce n'est pas toujours évident
[Musique]
de faire attention effectivement au
choix du restaurant mais malheureusement
on ne peut pas toujours tomber comme il
faut et
voilà et après les suites on les connaît
une heure après en général sinon vous
vous rendez compte la vie comme si
chaque fois on devait complètement
phobique de tout
on essaie de toute façon que fatalement
tous et on est similaires et demi sur la
planète on est en ingurgite tous les
jours des choses qui sont sûrement pas
très bonnes pour nous écouter après j'ai
demandé quand même s'il y a pas des
effets secondaires
à 10 km de là la ville médiévale
d'Aigues-Mortes et ses nombreux
restaurants touristiques
Yvan part à la pêche au fraude
[Musique]
et de dorade voilà bourride de l'autre
13,80 € bon c'est peut-être de la lotte
franchement de la lotte la vraie bon
c'est quand même difficile de les
retrouver après un menu à 19,80 € dans
une place aussi touristique que ça on il
est là aussi voilà un menu à 12,90 €
filet de loup normalement ces poissons
coûte très cher Monsieur pour avancer
voilà il y a un de vos employés et après
quand vous avez fini vous nous rejoignez
Yvan est intrigué par ces prix très
attractifs j'aimerais s'il vous plaît
que vous me montrez ce que vous avez un
stock en termes de loup de dorade et de
l'autre
OK
c'est de l'hôtel
pas tout à fait
c'est l'autre de Chine origine Chine
sur la carte et comme sur le menu du
jour il y a marqué bruit de l'hôtel
Boris de l'autre c'est réglementairement
prévu pour la lotte le poisson lot la
lotte d'ici là c'est le là c'est la
route de Chine
il faut que vous le sachiez en tout cas
son prix
ce qu'il faut que vous reteniez c'est
que la lotte tout court et la lotte de
Chine c'est pas le même poisson donc sur
votre carte il faut indiquer l’autre de
Chine alors ça peut paraître pas des
plus porteurs c'est possible mais
pourtant c'est ce qu'il faut faire
[Musique]
on va aller chercher c'est loin
Yvan a des soupçons sur d'autres
poissons inscrits à la carte on va
simplement le poser là pour l'instant
vous allez être démoralisé mais la Dora
de Sébastien de la droite la dorade
sébastes
c'est une dénomination commerciale tout
à fait légale ça aidera de Sébastien et
la dorade tout court malheureusement
c'est pas le même poisson que la droite
sébaste
donc tout ça entretien une confusion
et des méprises parfois
non mais ça c'est possible que ce soit
super beau mais c'est pas le même
poisson allez on vous laisse passer
devant parce que c'est chargé c'est pas
lourd
le restaurateur s'acquittera d'une
amende de 1500 euros pour dénominations
mensongères et il devra changer sa carte
à la petite semaine c'est de l'arnaque
généralisée alors bon
et il existe un autre poisson dont
l'origine est souvent usurpée l'un des
plus chers le loup aussi appelé bar à ne
pas confondre avec le loup de mer voilà
comme c'est beau
[Musique]
intuitivement on voit bien que le bar
d'abord qui est très rarement présenté
un filet qui achète un bar au restaurant
c'est le bar en entier tu vas chez le
poissonnier tu l'achètes il est en
entier c'est un beau poisson un bon
poisson etc le loup de mer c'est c'est
une tête c'est dégueulasse quoi tu ne
verras jamais un loup de mer tout seul
on va essayer de lui trouver s'il te
plaît une la tête d'un loup de mer là un
arrêt casse lupus et hideux tu tu mets
ça sur les tailles de Me poissonnier
tout le monde s'en va
c'est assez loin du bar quoi mais là
depuis le temps que ça existe cette
fraude là ça existe avant même que le
lot existe quoi
les gros poissons Lucien et Marie
Dominique les trouvent parfois sur les
marchés nocturnes
[Musique]
ce soir ils sont à Fréjus et pour
l'occasion ils sont accompagnés par des
policiers en civils
[Musique]
noirs
bon on se présente nous sommes
inspecteurs de la répression des fraudes
la direction départementale de la
protection des populations vous faites
le marché tous les jours ici tous les
thés
que vous a conseillé là-dessus pour la
vente de ces produits ou pas parce que
j'ai vu que ça se vendait j'ai vu que
c'est les fournisseurs donc je lui ai
dit pourquoi pas c'est un problème de
contrefaçon de marque
oui mais néanmoins
ça c'est quoi la vie est belle c'est
celui-là
à la limite ce qu'on vous conseillez
c'est d'enlever surtout les étiquettes
il y a des références à des marques
relativement connues
mais par exemple ici Nina Ricci numéro 5
sans commentaire avec un essai une
victime des c'est dur pour homme dès que
l'infraction est constatée la police
intervient à son tour
je vous en prendrai ce procès-verbal
la suite
ça sera quoi ce sera transmis au parquet
et ensuite le procureur décidera des
suites à donner sur la procédure
cette opération conjointe avec la police
permet d'accélérer les enquêtes en
saisissant le parquet plus rapidement et
les procédures elle permet aussi de
protéger les agents de la DDPP devant
cette autre stand les policiers restent
à distance et dissuadent le commerçant
d'un éventuel débordement
[Musique]
il y a rien en français
ce produit là vous l'avez comme ça comme
l'achetez vous avez la facture là du
fournisseur non bon des ballons il y en
a 9 10 11 12 13
ballons si on est appelé à relever nos
contraventions c'est par nombre
d'articles que la contravention est
relevée donc 13 ballons 13
compréhensions parce que c'est pas
normal de trouver des
moi je sais pas comment ça marche pour
une simple amende le montant peut
s'élever à 1500 euros pour ces 13
ballons malédictés le fournisseur risque
un PV de 10.000 euros des sommes qui
suscitent parfois des réactions
agressives de la part de certains
commerçants si jamais ça peut
il y a beaucoup de monde quand même donc
je pense pas qu'un commerçant s'amuse
à être grossier ou violent
mais néanmoins on peut constater qu'il y
a moi géré une dégradation qui peut de
la relation humaine et qui existe entre
contrôleur contrôlé
pour X raisons c'est la société qui
évolue certainement aussi moi j'apprécie
en tout cas
protéger et puis par plusieurs personnes
même
ça c'est de la nacre c'est de la nacre
de la nacre du plastique
à Avignon au siège de la DDPP Marie
Carmen elle travaille plus sereinement
elle s'intéresse de Préaux tarifs d'une
maison d'hôtes
je pense que la plus chère c'est la
première
est-ce qu'il nous donne le prix là
au lieu de 230
[Musique]
au départ quand les gens ouvrent les
chambres d'hôtes
leur conception était que c'était pas un
hôtel donc ils avaient l'impression que
ils étaient pas soumis au même règle que
l'hôtel donc on essaie de rééquilibrer
un petit peu surtout que là on arrive
bon dès qu'on arrive sur des chambres
d'hôtes introductions on arrive sur des
prix qui dépassent
le prix de la majorité des hôtels
la maison d'hôtes est située dans le
Parc Naturel du Luberon dans un luxueux
domaine d'un hectare Marie Carmen agent
de la DDPP contrôle cette luxueuse
maison d'hôtes
c'est l'avantage de des contrôles il y a
des fois on voit de très jolis trucs
ah non mais c'est
donc c'est là c'est laquelle voilà c'est
la chambre essentielle d'accord alors
une petite chose qui vous a un petit peu
interpellé donc on a vu vos prix
affichés à l'extérieur et sur le site et
après on se rend compte que quand on va
par exemple sur réservé les prix sont un
peu plus beau
ça c'est c'est les prix qu'on a quand on
fait les tarifs après quand on déroule
vous savez les chambres on a ces prix là
donc je vous le dis quand ça c'est les
prix basse saison ça c'est les prix en
fait le site internet le module de
réservation prend les prix les plus bas
et ensuite quand vous notez les dates il
vous donne le prix de la nuit actualisé
d'accord oui parce qu'on comprenait pas
certains prix affichés sont ceux de la
basse saison il ne correspond pas
toujours à ce que paye réellement les
clients
la gérante devra mettre à jour son site
internet et changer aussi le nom d'une
de ses prestations
il y a des prestations qui sont
gratuites
et le hammam donc la séance est payante
elle est à 30 euros les massages les
massages
idem ça fait partie ils sont faits par
une prestataire donc qui est en
freelance un professionnel
[Musique]
donc si elle est pas une professionnelle
de la santé il va falloir enlever le mot
massage c'est les diplômes que m'a donné
que me laver la praticienne en arrivant
c'est tout en anglais je sais pas où
c'est que c'est fait c'est des instituts
c'est des certificats mais ça pas une
je pense que ça n'a aucune valeur voilà
elle va être contente de l'apprendre
alors ça aucune valeur quand on prenne
bien sûr pour pouvoir employer le mot
massage parce qu'en fait les clients
étrangers ils connaissent pas le mot de
l'âge mais là il va falloir lui marquer
nos massages sont des modelages
corporels donc thérapeutiques non
médicalisés il faudra quand même nous
enlever le mot massage donc voilà donc
là on fera on vous enverra un petit
courrier pour bien vous rappeler la
réglementation allez on va à la piscine
le mari de la propriétaire qui l'emmène
ensuite vérifier la piscine
donc en matière d'affichage
qui sont ici
pour ce qui concerne le bassin
laquelle profondeur votre piscine alors
on varie de 1 m 10 1m90 vous avez un
mètre 90 ici
alors
mon petit souci c'est que c'est pas très
visible
donc ce qui serait peut-être bien pour
la saison prochaine c'est plutôt que de
le mettre sur le bord
c'est de le mettre comme ça là
parce que la notion est donnée que ça
doit être visible du bassin
vous voyez quand la personne est dans
l'eau c'est pas visible voilà alors une
évidence quand même puisque vous avez un
bassin qui en pente douce et je pense
que le chèque
et on va donc grosso modo vous voilà il
me manque juste à améliorer on va dire
ce marquage donc
on peut trouver parfois un règlement un
peu tâtillon mais s'il a été édicté
c'est qu'il sert à quelque chose même si
en tant que Français on n'aime pas trop
ça c'est sûr
en 22 ans de service Marie Carmen a
procédé à des milliers d'inspection à un
an de la retraite elle a le sentiment du
devoir accompli
moi par exemple par rapport au moment où
j'ai commencé
l'amélioration on l'a vu donc ça prouve
que quand même on sert à quelque chose
voilà donc cette notion d'utilité voilà
de pouvoir rendre rendre service puis la
notion de service public qui quand même
important je pense qu'on y est quand
même attaché
anime Yvan et Jean-Pierre viennent de
recevoir des résultats d'analyse des
échantillons de poissons et de fruits de
mer prélevés chez le traiteur du gros du
roi
mauvais résultats
[Musique]
en fait
donc
c'est un bien grand mot mais bon c'est
des produits ce sont des germes qui
globalement sont détruit par la chaleur
mais si sa cuisson n'est pas parfaite il
va en rester et c'est ce qu'on a c'est
ce qu'on a pu par exemple c'est ce qu'on
a pu déterminer c'est ce que laboratoire
a pu déterminer quand il nous a fait le
résultat
ça veut dire que ils savent pas beaucoup
les mains alors après
sur 7 qui pose ce problème là il y a les
supions un Scipion grillés
farci c'est bon le filet de rouget aussi
le temps la provençale la sèche aussi
c'est chez toi ce qui pose des problèmes
pareil il y a un taux de
micro-organismes aérobie alors ça qui
échantillons sur 7 sont contaminés par
des bactéries le commerçant risque
environ 3000 euros d'amende
de revoir ces procédés de mes au-delà de
la sanction Yvan espère que leur travail
permettra aux professionnels d'améliorer
ses pratiques ce que ça nous inspire
c'est qu'il faut surtout pas baisser la
garde il faut pas baisser la garde parce
que ils vont pas redresser là-bas tout
seul ça l'expérience le montre et quand
il y a des problèmes d'hygiène on
s'aperçoit aussi que les autres aspects
de la réglementation la loyauté
l'information du consommateur on fait
essayer de pas le prendre quand même bon
un peu trop pour voilà un bonnet mais on
s'aperçoit que c'est aussi ça suit pas
c'est c'est tout à volo quoi donc il
faut vraiment vraiment avoir un oeil sur
ses professionnels dès qu'on les a
identifié parce que on sait que ça peut
vraiment aller vers du n'importe quoi
donc renforcer la vigilance
faire l'histoire de l'été s'achève mais
pas leur mission ils vont le sait
améliorer la qualité des produits vendus
dans son secteur est un travail de
longue haleine là on est comme un des
sportifs on laisse tomber une saison on
pense déjà à se préparer pour la saison
prochaine
mais en cette fin de mois d'août la
saison n'est pas terminée pour tout le
monde
un péage d'autoroute près de Brignoles
dans le Var
Lucien y accompagne Charlotte et Sabrina
de stagiaires
c'est leur tout premier contrôle
c'est pour ça
celui-là
transporte
sur le parking
peut-être pas trop perdu là
c'est vrai que ça ça surprend un peu le
dispositif
tout un fruit
alors là
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire il va le
recongeler derrière
un produit a été décongelé le camionneur
est en infraction
mais il va tenter de profiter du manque
d'expérience de Charlotte
c'est pas la même chose et votre nom
s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
merci bonne route au revoir
bonne journée le fait d'exiger
l'identité avec la personne refuse
finalement
on a le droit d'exiger
il y a vraiment un risque physique avec
avec des contrôlés des
exceptionnellement
nous on doit rester à notre place
on doit faire en sorte de pouvoir faire
notre travail calmement sereinement en
restant poli des fois c'est pas facile
c'est pas facile
j'ai défendu je pense j'ai essayé de le
servir du mieux possible mais bon ce
passage au relais moi je le trouve
sympathique dans la mesure on a aussi
des gens réceptifs
qui mordent
de Toulon donc ça c'est intéressant et
c'est un peu le compagnonnage
pour Lucien ce métier est aussi une
passion qui déborde parfois sur sa vie
privée
[Musique]
qui vivent ensemble ça fait des clashs
s'il continue les marchés depuis tant
d'années c'est aussi parce que Lucien
est un bon vivant
il y a un côté un peu bonbons anglais un
goût des bons produits qu'il a aussi
transmis à ses enfants
[Musique]
par rapport à l'hygiène et par rapport à
l'alimentation par rapport aux
normes et enfin vraiment l'hygiène quoi
ça permet à ce qu'on va au restaurant en
fait de se dire qu'il y a quand même des
personnes qui contrôle ça évite de
manger un petit peu n'importe quoi
j'apprends et puis c'est vrai que des
fois
fois mes amis au restaurant je me dis ah
bah tiens là ils ont pas bien fait telle
chose ou
on apprend aussi c'est important pour
vous d'avoir inculqué ça à vos enfants
mais je pense que ça a dû prendre quand
même un petit peu parce que quand je
suis invité chez eux
on mange pas mal
donc ça me fait plaisir
comme les policiers les agents de la
DDPP sont parfois sous pression
lorsqu’ils multiplient les contrôles
dans leur métier savoir décompresser est
essentiel
Lucien et Marie Dominique le font en
famille Gilles lui le fait sur son
bateau avec ses amis on va essayer de
mettre ce qui se passe une compétition
de
une compétition de de view hackers de
vieux de vieux Waker c'est à dire que ça
fait ouais ouais mais là ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas fait et on est
impatient de se mettre à l'eau et d'y
rester d'ailleurs
il est bon ouais que j'ai un petit vieux
en plus
allez les moussaillons vous mettez vous
relevez les gouttes
c'est chouette de bosser ici non
c'est chouette de bosser partout c'est
chouette de bosser d'ailleurs mais mais
ici c'est vrai que on a la possibilité
après de se détendre avec des passions
différentes
d'autres régions non on serait on se
concerne le ski bon enfin on aura fait
aussi quand même
je vais essayer de pas te blesser fais
gaffe ils ont plus les mêmes réflexes
à peu près où on peut aller manger quoi
c'est ce qui est pas mal
et d'autres d'autres qualités il en a
pas
faut être clair il en a pas
[Musique]
et pour une fois
ce jour-là
j'ai loin des contrôles ça permet
d'oublier c'est un poids chaque
inspection
on fait plein d'autres choses mais on
parle pas beaucoup
ça y est allez
[Musique]
quelques heures de répit pour finir un
été mouvementé en trois mois Gilles
Lucien Yvan et Marie Carmen auront
réalisé à EU4 près de 300 contrôles et
distribués près de 100000 euros d'amende
une vigilance de tous les instants au
service de nos vacances le temps d'un
été à la DDPP
[Musique]